ça va olivier écoute tout moment ça va
ça va aller 6 me sur a faites vous
plaisir à se libérer mais surtout ne
vous gênez pas pour moi non elles font
le tour des continents on les grave et
difficilement mais ce l'est tenir c'est
quand même beaucoup rire qui sautait le
lit et me jette rien compris
des continents on les grave y
difficilement mais ce l'est tenir c'est
quand même beaucoup rire
qui sont-elles elles font tourner
continents chez elle peut-être de boeuf
aussi à de boeuf l'onglet n'ont pas
autant dire la côte locaux peut-être la
corne note au sein ce qui entoure le
lapin thorax le thorax du marais je suis
content ou comment honorer son rôle à un
débat à la joue là que la donne car au
musée aux commandes toujours une queue
de boeuf mais aussi en se mettant les
mains sur le haut niveau pro se tient
les cantons des comptes les contre 94,84
danse kilos pour 1 mètre 91 et évoquant
20,90 pardon avait 90 ans en train de
toulon ouais d'accord il fait la même
taille que vous c'est faux 35 kg doivent
quand même pas attention au voc tard
c'est tous les deux droitiers
c'est à moi de faire le bras de fer que
tout le monde a strange alcudia d'un
coup de tête et bien que ça va beaucoup
de monde
on dirait la durée la vénus de milo
alors qu'ils ont su attention c'est
parti
top oh la la allez il est temps sur le
coude le coude attentionné conjugaux de
la plante sur la table le coude soit 1 5
mo kourouma malo tech
[Rires]
bonjour alors on joue mal et c'est parti
ils vivent à m'écraser lanta de salon
une autre à 200 euros alesi de sauvons
nous retrouver retient grille mais pas
celle des programmes olivier avant on
m'apprend parfois pour une chipeau
lorsqu'on fait des amalgames une chose
soit magloire les muscles et un copeau
êtes vous catherine dupin du couscous on
peut me déguster qui est elle
avec du pain et du couscous du qu'est-ce
qu'on peut manger avec du pain et du
couscous et vous l'êtes n'ont d'autre
chose que les boulettes
on peut manger elle est longue
elle est longue elle est mince quelques
passants
[Rires]
saint gilles verdez à la merguez murguet
[Musique]